good morning everybody and welcome to
the meeting of development control v
committee now i first of all remind you
of some domestic arrangements please
ensure ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons whilst
in the chamber and in the communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face
covering at all times unless you're
sitting down or if you are exempt from
doing so and that you use the hand
sanitizer and whites provided
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations while
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you will be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
we will be using e-voting for this
meeting on the modern gov app so please
could members make sure they are logged
in and ready to use the app
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those sound recording
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may record film or photograph or
broadcast this meeting
when
the public and press are not lawfully
excluded if you hear the alarm leave the
building immediately via the fire exit
and make your way to the assembly point
which is ipswich town football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exits at each end of the floor do
not enter the atrium which is the ground
floor area and walkways if you are in
the atrium at any time of the alarm
follow the signs to the nearest fire
exit
use the stairs not the lifts do not
re-enter the building until you are told
it is safe to do so
so the introductions we have in decree
our legal advisor
morning
we have gemma walker
our area planning manager we have robert
carmichael our governance officer we
have the planning officers sean and
massa
and we also have our heritage officer
thomas pinner who's sitting there and
just so that everybody knows this is
becky who's live streaming for us
um do we have any ward members present
no
i believe you have a statement from a
ward member thank you
so can i move on to the agenda please
apologies for absence and substitutions
thank you chair we have apologies this
morning from councillor andrew stringer
with councillor john matheson
substituting and we have just received
apologies from council roland ward boys
thank you chair
thank you very much do we have any
declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interest by members
yes councillor
just to put on record that i am the
county councillor for tostock night for
various reasons i happen to be on tosta
parish council at the moment as well
thank you for that councilman
do we have any declarations of lobbying
declarations of personal site visits
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 1st of september
we have papers here for them
can i have a proposal in the secondary
councillor
thank you councillor mellon
so happy to second yeah thank you very
much indeed
so may we have the electronic vote
please now
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress in the modern.gov app so if
members please go to the plus sign in
the top right hand corner of the agenda
and go to the subsection on voting slash
attendance the vote will show in a light
blue color
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is five votes for and
two abstentions so that is carried
thank you very much
the minutes of the meeting have been
confirmed and will be signed
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
non-received chair thank you
and the schedule of planning
applications will be the order in which
we already have them which is
dc2100584 land between red house and
annie supple cottage the street ricking
hall so i'll now invite the case officer
sean bunbury to introduce the
application to the committee please
thank you sean
thank you chair so this planning
application
was deferred from the meeting back in
july
which was held at the debenham uh
community center
and the application was deferred
to seek confirmation of
distances and dimensions distances of
the proposed dwelling from the
boundaries in particular
there was also some discussion as to
whether um the
design of the dwelling whether the size
of it might be reduced slightly and also
whether there could be some
clarification on sustainability issues
and the application has been called in
by the ward member
so i think quite a number of councillors
here today were at that meeting in july
but i'll go through the presentation uh
just for clarification
yes just to say that obviously i was not
not at the meeting in july and also to
say that i seem to recognize this case
from a long time ago i have seen it
before
i would also just like to point out that
we've received a further neighbor letter
in support which is in addition to one
which has already been received from a
property at honeysuckle cottage and a
new neighbor letter supporting the
application from the old four horseshoes
and i'll point out that property as i go
through the presentation
the comments from the parish council in
the uh report are
summarized as that they support the
application and their comments are in
further detail on page 27 in the papers
so i'll go through the agenda through
the presentation
so the site is shown hatched in pink
it's located to the north west side of
the street in wrecking hall
shown
so i just need to get used to the mouse
in this location here with an access
into the main part of the site to the
rear
so this is just a broader picture of the
development um in the street
and as you can see
the site is set back behind the frontage
properties in this location
here the purple line and the hatched um
well the purple line on the outside of
the hatched area shows the boundaries of
the conservation area
so the site is within the conservation
area
it's within the brown line which is the
settlement boundary
and the orange buildings are listed
buildings so this listed building to the
southwest of the site is the old four
horseshoes
and the site is well outside the flood
zones to the north west
so again just a little bit closer and
showing the access into the site
and the extent of the site to the rear
of red house which is to the west and
honeysuckle cottage which is to the
northeast
so this shows the access into the site
shows the proposed location of the
dwelling which is a two-bedroom dwelling
up towards the northeast corner
and the dimensions of the site which you
can probably see clearer um in your
papers and on your own screens
are the dimensions for which we have
received clarification
so the main one of interest really which
was
under discussion at the previous meeting
is the dimension from the ban from the
elevation
to this boundary of the site
and that is
11.6
meters
the rest of the dimensions are also
clearly updated in the main report
so on this plan also you can see
the position of the red house
and honeysuckle cottage
this plan shows the proposed landscaping
scheme
with the access into the site
granite
parking and turning area
1.8 meter high fencing to the boundary
here
proposed planting and the retention of
this tree on the southwest boundary
this is a previous scheme that was
granted permission 2003
so it's just for information really and
it is referred to in the heritage
comments and that shows a frontage
dwelling
with an access through
to parking at the rear
this application in 2020
was withdrawn prior to determination
and this shows that the dwelling at that
stage proposed was an l shape so it was
slightly larger than you have before you
today
and these are the plans and elevations
of that application which was withdrawn
and as you can see that was a three
bedroom property
so these are the previous withdrawn
application and that was the street
elevation at that time
and this actually does usefully show the
difference in the ground level between
the application site
and the drop down of about a meter or so
to the
adjacent property
so this is the location of the building
which we have before us
it has moved slightly further
towards this uh northern corner
from
the consideration in july and there is a
small reduction in the
floor area
so what we have before us today um is an
open plan
on the ground floor and a bathroom in
that corner
and then two bedrooms
which are linked by
a sort of walkway with a void on either
side
and as you can see on the roof plan
there's solar panel
and there are four roof lights shown two
on each roof slope
so a section through which does show
that
walkway up at first floor level with the
void either side
so these are the elevations this is the
elevation which would be facing the
street towards the street
and this elevation is the one facing
towards the private garden for the
dwelling
so on here we have red brick to the
plinth
vertical timber boarding
pan tiles
and there are also
bird boxes shown
attached or incorporated into part of
the elevations
and this window here which faces towards
the street and and the rear of the
frontage properties
is a small partially obscured
window
so the street elevation obviously the
property is set back from the street but
it shows it in relation to the frontage
dwellings
this is the red house
we've got letters of objection from the
red house this is beam cottage and
honeysuckle cottage from which we have
letters of support
this indicates the proposed visibility
display uh it is an existing access
although my understanding is that the
red house
parking is provided on streets so there
is on-street parking all along the site
frontage
and the visibility display
is acceptable to highways
and this also indicates
parking and maneuvering
the cars are shown as being
4.2 by 1.8
meters as drawn
parking spaces required by highways are
normally
5 by 2.5
and
in terms of the conclusion and
recommendation you will see that there
is some
concern on the officers part about the
actual practicality of that maneuvering
on the site
this is an additional drawing to that
which we had before us in july
but it does indicate some of the
environmental credentials
one of the um
objectives i ought to have pointed out
originally there was also a comment
about
the lack of public benefit that was
discussed last time around as well quite
significantly and these environmental
credentials
are indicated in support of the overall
benefits of the scheme
with features such as the solar thermal
hot water panel on the roof
and the bird nesting boxes mechanical
heat ventilation
and
a sort of fabric first to avoid
loss of heat through the structure and
fabric of the building
the existing tree on the site boundary
um would be protected during the course
of construction
and i now have some photographs which
were taken back in the summer but they
indicate the street frontage um
along
uh wrecking hall street so the
application site is in
behind here where those trees are shown
so this flint property here is the old
four horseshoes that is the listed
building
then you have bean cottage and the red
house
and the gap
which forms the site frontage between
red house and honeysuckle cottage
so this is where the site access is
formed there is an existing drop curve
but it's formed in that area
you can see that honeysuckle cottage has
got a flat roof extension to the side
and the extension continues to the rear
so this is the rear of honeysuckle
cottage so this is the
north east boundary of the site
and looking at that boundary again from
the other side of the site
and a little bit further down this is
the rest of the
northeastern boundary
this is the adjacent property
radgate house so the dwelling itself is
here and these are garages and
outbuildings and you can see some
greenhouses there the proposed location
of the dwelling is in this corner here
at the back of the side
again that's the property to the
northeast
and the boundary
further
away so this is looking at the rear of
the red house which as you can see he's
got three first floor windows and the
white there is the rear of the listed
building
so this is obviously from from the
application proposed dwelling looking
back towards the road frontage
and other
boundaries looking back towards that
frontage development with the tree
that's being retained
and this is looking towards the rear of
the site which is well treed behind
and then the
highway frontage looking towards the
southeast
and towards the northwest as you can see
the
on street parking
and then just as a reminder of the
position
of the site
and the proposed street elevation
so the concerns um really are over the
impact on the character of the
conservation area uh residential amenity
um
the impact on the non-designated
heritage assets which
is a policy which features in the local
neighborhood plan
and the concern
of the officers is such that it leads to
the recommendation of refusal on those
bases thank you
thank you very much for that before i go
to questions
i've just jotted down a question here
slide seven could you put slide seven
mac up please
it's showing um it's right at the
beginning it's the
the um sort of
the paper version of that
yes um i have a question here it may
well be for the applicant so i apologize
if it's wrong which is why i've jumped
in now
um
at the moment if one has
you you say that the the officers have a
worry about parking and turning
if there is a car parked in the bottom
bit near where the trees are allegedly
and there are two car no there yeah if
there's a car parked there
how would the car if there's a car park
straight in
turn because it wouldn't really be able
to go around the corners is that your is
that your worry that's what i'm trying
to get at if not it would have to come
out backwards i would assume
is that the concern i
chairman the concern is that um
the parking spaces as shown on on one of
the other layout plans if there's a car
parked um near where those trees are and
one in front of the dwelling
maneuvering would be difficult
they would need to maneuver on site
because it really would not be
acceptable to come out
and reverse out of the property okay and
so there would need to have parking and
turning accommodated which overall
um offices are concerned is an
indication of the cramped nature of the
development right and you're going to
love me on this one and i apologize to
members because i'm sure you all have
your own markings for it can you go back
to 21 please because i noticed there was
um
one of them that showed the elevations
um and
this 21 sort of that one seemed to not
show it as powerfully as one of the
other ones and i forgot what the other
one was that it showed that there was a
height difference there was a higher
part am i right
maybe not
maybe as we go through we'll have a look
at the rest of them but anyway okay so
members sorry i sort of jumped the gun
on that one a little bit do you have
questions councillor matheson thank you
and thank you yeah a couple
on that very slightly i did wonder what
those two polls one each side of the
proposed dwelling actually were were
they trying to tell us something about
the height because i imagine they're not
chimneys or flagpoles um
and and i think we came back to that on
slide 48 which is
actually the same slide really the other
question was where um notices that there
was a slider photograph that showed the
drop curb
um
so i i kind of started to think about
that you know was that an old
agricultural access or whatever or and
then
actually where's the parking for for a
red house which is the one to the left
as we're looking at it i think
where's their parking is this perhaps
pinching their parking by any chance
uh so if i can talk about these two
that's a telegraph poll
holding up the telegraph wires
it's a telegraph poll uh this is um a
flu on the proposed dwelling
um the parking um
the land ownership in the application
site has changed over the last 20 or 30
years
and parking for red house is
my understanding is on the street
and councillor muller you have a
question thank you councillor matheson
thank you thank you chair um the
question asked by councilman matthewson
was exactly the same question i was
going to ask chair so thank you oh thank
you councillor gould
i should but i also um wanted to know
the in the
uh
in the northern
corner in the northeastern corner what's
the difference between the proposed
dwelling and the boundary
it looked very tight indeed
uh this
distance at the rear here
that one is
1.3 meters
and to that boundary there
is
3.6 meters i think
uh
and uh
other members of the committee
i now have some expertise on on this
particular matter and it's about
the effectiveness of the solar
panels
given the orientation of the of the
building
are they
for show or will they be truly effective
on that orientation
um they're facing um westish they're for
um
heating water
heating and
i i'm not an expert on how effective
they would be obviously there would be
it's probably not the ideal um
orientation but it may be that the
applicant or agent might have a bit more
information on that
thank you for that any further questions
for the officer councillor custon and
then councillor norris and i'll come
back to you councillor matherson
thank you um
on that sort of northwest well it on
that
on that picture it's the north boundary
what is that land on the other side of
that fence um
so yeah that that bit of land um
do we know who owns it or what purpose
uh excuse me cancer i don't think that's
really relevant to to what we're doing
would you agree um
well it is a boundary of 1.3 meters yeah
let me just ask you yeah okay if you
don't mind i don't think there's any
harm in the question being answered we
can then decide how relevant and how
much right
thank you thank you councillor thank you
for that are you thank you
the photograph showed that that's just a
well-treed um bit of land um whether it
goes with the adjacent property
um
on this side here these are out
buildings and this is where the uh
greenhouses were shown on some of the
photographs um and the house called
bradgate is is this one here whether
their um land extends beyond the rear of
the site i'm not sure but it's it's a
sort of
treed
um area it's not it's not sort of used
as garden as such but whether it is
domestic garden i'm not sure
thank you
and councillor norris please
thank you man madam chair
um i too have a issue with the parking
arrangements on the site plan on page
54. they're trying to ask a question we
can go into debate on that one which is
pretty good i don't understand how the
car on the right-hand side is going to
maneuver around or exit in forward gear
anyway uh perhaps the applicant can
verify that uh when they speak um part
17
in the middle of the page there is a
list of objections and the last one says
encroaches on land not owned by
applicant uh football officer please
clarify that or is this something we've
already covered previously
i think the issue
is the land ownership question is not
directly of
a planning matter but we have had
letters of correspondence
and i think it's to do with um part of
the land as i say about during the 1990s
i think being sold off from the red
house
there is the question as to whether this
particular location here where the car
is parked is in fact in the applicant's
ownership the applicants um assure me it
is but it's it's obviously open to some
um
discussion between the the two parties
as to exactly who owns the land
thank you for that can i just ask
clarity on that ian um is that relevant
for our debate today
thank you
thank you for that
councillor matheson you had a
supplementary question if you yeah yes
um
i think
the legitimate version of council
carson's question is what is the land
use designation um adjacent there that
would be a fair question surely that is
material but also what i was wondering
about was from on councillor goulds
could we see something that shows the
relative height of that tree
compared to the
solar panel because um
i think he has a fair point
about the efficiency if it's also shaded
then we're really looking at something
that's not much good
so there's an interesting point cancer
and i think that will come up in debate
but if sean can give us a clue of the
height um
that so that that's the tree in question
there
may be counsellor we can ask the agent a
little further when we just get on to
the next little bit you can ask your
question again if you would
thanks counsellor
so i now
like to invite
the parish council
jeff short and you have three minutes to
address the committee if you would
please thank you very much
thank you very much chairman
um
we as you know the parish council
approved um the application
and this is a local family
uh living on a small estate at present
and the land's been in the family for
some time and the application to build
an individual family home is obviously
what they they want to achieve
as you've seen on the pictures that
currently it is sort of wasteland and
fenced off and i've lived in the village
10 years and it's looked exactly like
that for 10 years
and it's nice that actually somebody
wants to do something with it um the
previous application in 2020 was
withdrawn to address comments from the
planning and conservation offices
and consequently it was made smaller as
we've already heard
windows were altered and rather
drastically they've gone three bed to
two bed
they have obviously moved a lot of
things to try and comply and fit it in
in accordance with the conservation
request
yes it is in a conservation area but
there's non-listed cottages to either
side
it's going to be a barn an outbuilding
style setback as we've seen
and the heritage officer says it's not
in keeping and we can't quite understand
why because there are various examples
of properties set back down the entrance
ways barn style exactly the same
in fact one um one of the bits on the
application showed pictures with arrows
pointing to sort of three driveways they
are all within two or three cottages of
that property
and in fact the one that you've showed
showing the
outbuildings to the right
also shows that properties are set back
they are built alongside the applicant's
side
and it certainly isn't unusual in fact
there are some of the more interesting
bits down the street when you do get
these little things offset
so the existing um accompanying map
shows as i say the very close proximity
so we thought it did confirm to the
neighborhood plan it is in keeping and
we can't really see any reason to object
on um
conservation or heritage grounds
and that's it thank you thank you
um
thank you
thank you
um so
we now have
the applicant joe irvine and you have
three minutes to speak if you would
please thank you very much thank you
good morning
application was presented to you in july
and you proposed to support the
application but wanted to check the
dimensions to understand how you can
approve a proposal with a low level of
heritage harm
i'm joe laura irvine and i are the
applicants for this development we
currently live in the village and laura
was born and raised in the village and
is very home to her close family as well
we are very much part of the community
this is our dream home a growing family
home and a village so dear to us we're
not building something for profit we're
building something we can be proud of in
the village
the application site has been in the
family for a long time and i'm a
bricklayer and hoping to build our house
and build it far above the usual
environmental standards
as shown in the drawings in response to
your comments we have marked the
drawings with more dimensions the house
has been made slightly smaller and move
further back because your question if
cars could turn on site and we confirm
that they will be able to
we submit the application last year and
had comments about heritage and
overlooking we went through the
application to deal with these issues
but we have good local support
the objectives have commented because
we're in a family legal dispute with him
about the site boundary our law is very
clear that we're in the right and
unfortunately the dispute still does not
go away which is very upsetting for our
family the heritage officer only finds a
low level of harm commenting that
development is carried
characteristically one plot deep this is
not the case as you see from the slides
two and three there's not there is a lot
of development behind the frontage
houses the house is designed in the
style of a suffolk barn and similar
outbuildings are common behind the
houses and there are examples nearby it
said that development would close the
gap with the red house the area is
already enclosed by mature trees and
already fenced in with a six foot fence
the red house is also not a listed
building the parish who has a
neighborhood plan support this
application don't feel this harms the
area a 2003 grant a permission
for the house on the front could not be
built today as the site is not in one
ownership and there are services over
the front of the
driveway that cannot be built over and
we have explored every option on this
three immediate neighbors have written
in support they don't think the cars
will affect them the site already has
road access and can be used for parking
now we are happy to properly fence and
put trees along the boundaries to make
sure we do not disturb the neighbours as
shown in the plans
our planning consultant has agreed
several planning applications with
offices where benefits can outweigh low
level of heritage
the relevant benefits you can see in the
case are the social benefits of
providing a house that meets local needs
reusing a vacant sustainably located
site economic benefits from construction
and from new residents and construction
of an energy efficient home there is
a recent mid suffix precedent of these
benefits being used in applications like
this to justify this type of development
and i hope you will support this
application and we'll be happy to answer
any questions
thank you very much thank you
well actually yes i do have one question
sorry am i allowed to go back i am um
you say you're a growing family
and this is a two-bedroom property
what's going to stop you making the two
voids into a third bedroom
boys but we could use i grew up in a
two-bed house no no what's going to
what would stop you
making it into a third bedroom if you're
a growing family
uh i think it's more to do with this
light in the actual space because it's
an open plan downstairs and we want to
keep the light coming in the roof lights
and everything rather than enclosed or
complete downstairs and have a single
storey you can have it sort of opened up
and it won't be as
so is it like a mezzanine walkway across
yes yeah yeah with like a little office
but where the stairs come out there'll
be a little office space for us as well
okay thank you for that explanation
thank you
right um
i believe robert you have a statement
from the ward member if you finally read
that out for us thank you
thank you i'll just get that
for us
so i have statements from ward
councillor jessica fleming regarding the
wrecking hall application
again i am writing on behalf of the
applicant for this application which is
recommended by officers for refusal as
with the previous presentation i
apologize for not being present in
person as i am on leave my comments on
this application do not differ from
those i provided previously however i
would like to to point out that the
applicant has gone to added lengths to
improve the design by providing details
of sustainability measures and adjusting
the footprint slightly to allow
more unbuilt space for vehicles or other
uses
it does not appear as if it would be
cramped
and it isn't common for urban homes to
have no space at all for cars to park
and turn within their cartilage
no street parking will be required
i feel that this is a suitable design
for the location in response to the
local need for moderately sized central
residential living and fills a gap in
the more or less linear pattern of homes
in this part of the village the proposal
has again received active support from
the parish council
i have not seen any new neighbour
comments lodged for this amended
proposal prior comments are summarized
to give the perspective of the list on
page 17 of the papers
neighbor adjacent to the right comments
submitted saturday the 12th
sorry saturday 20th february 2021 i live
in honeysuckle costume
so we'll
be neighbours to this build i believe
this build and the family who'll be
living there will be a positive addition
to the street i totally support this
application and look forward to them
seeing the house take shape
neighbour comment bm
bm cottage comment submitted date
thursday the fourth feb 2021
we are neighbors of the land concerning
planning application
and although their garden will be
joining us we have no objection to this
application we feel that new neighbours
would be beneficial to the area and we
know that the couple concerned our
decent upstanding people of the
community
the land would benefit from having a
dwelling on it as as it would enhance
what
what is
currently wasteground we have seen the
hard work that has already been done by
the applicants in preparing the area
and are looking forward to having a
younger family as our neighbours
neighbor neighbour
chair do you want me to continue reading
out these neighbour comments on these
just to confirm that's part of this
this is in the statement yes
that's what i just want to check that
when i'm not repeating something that's
these are comments i believe they're
online i'll carry on i just wanted to
make that point before we
jason to red house pm williams objects
this neighbor objects on the basis of
land ownership which i understand may be
a separate legal issue between the
parties
party living in halston but related or
linked to the occupants of red house
objects comments on surroundings of red
house problems with parking and traffic
loss of immunity as per list on page 17.
the proposal is for a fairly
modest dwelling
and i believe it represents an overall
benefit to the local area
notwithstanding its location in a
conservation area
any development in a conservation area
cannot but change its carrier character
at some level and a degree of change or
harm is generally accepted in planning
decision making
the heritage officer has identified a
low level of less than substantial harm
associated with the proposal
to overcome this the architect has gone
to some lengths to work with the
heritage officer and has proposed a
design that is in keeping with the other
buildings and heritage setting as well
as offering a substantial sustainable
features professional heritage
assessment has been prepared a key
question is how it is a possible low
level of harm sufficient grounds for
refusal given the benefits of providing
an additional modestly sized home in a
desirable and suitable location
i do not believe
that this is the case and that the very
small amount of harm if any does not
justify refusal nor does it contravene
relevant planning policy
i would like to address the general
acceptability of the proposal as
evidenced by comments from neighbours
and the parish council
the proposal has a list two public
comments in support including the
adjacent east side property as well as
a second statement in support from the
parish council
i was present when the first application
was discussed in public
and general feeling was very positive
that this new
dwelling would be a great improvement
upon the present situation and would
provide welcome housing for a local
family the location is within the
village envelope and does not conflict
with the aims and vision of the wrecking
hall bottasdale neighbourhood plan nor
with relevant policies in the local plan
or nppf
it enjoys active local support which is
somewhat unusual for most planning
applications i have visited the site and
enclosed two paragraph photographs in
july which you may or may not be able to
view
having considered the various issues
raised by officers and consultees i see
no grounds for refusal and substantial
benefit from enabling this small-scale
development to proceed i therefore ask
members to consider the application
objectively and to grant consent
thank you that's councillor
thank you very thank you very much for
that and of course
that was very
full um before we actually move on um i
think it's going to enter into the
debate
is regarding the um
the parking being one of the issues and
the turning
and i wondered if i could um ask thomas
pinner to just sort of
outline um a little bit more about the
heritage concerns regarding parking and
i would also refer members to page
48 which actually shows a photograph of
a car parked across the entrance
on street parking there which i think
was something councillor matherson
brought up i can't remember without
parking um but i wonder if if thomas you
could just sort of amplify a little for
us
the concerns regarding that issue
um i'm i'd say i'm not sure that we have
raised any concerns specifically with
the parking in heritage
was it not i thought
sean did you not mention
okay i beg your pardon maybe it wasn't
your good self then
i must admit i have been leaving
chair i think we have got two reasons
for refusals there's the heritage issue
right and then a parking one as well
which relates to me right we'll come
back to you then thomas if there's some
heritage issues i'm sorry i beg your
pardon
i've sort of um quickly skimmed and
looked at it okay then so we now open to
the council of mueller
thank you chair um yes very interesting
uh debate thank you very much for all
the people um answering the questions
etc i do have serious concerns with this
one chair i'm afraid um
if we can see slide 21 please again
and one of my main issues of concern is
the diagram is completely out of
character with other properties
shown next to either side of that
property and i refer to paragraph 130 of
the
national policy planning framework
are sympathetic to local character and
history including the surrounding built
environment and landscape setting we're
not preventing or discouraging
appropriate innovation or change well i
suppose you could argue it's innovative
but
to me personally i accept this is a
personal opinion i do not think it is
sympathetic to the the other properties
on that street
i do have serious concerns about the
parking that's been issued and the
comments raised by my colleague
councillor gould about the solar panels
on the roof and the height of the tree
and will this actually be very effective
so
at this moment in time i'm tending to
agree with the officer's recommendation
thank you chair
thank you council councillor mellon
thank you chair um
i remember when we discussed this back
at debenham and um
i think actually pretty much
the committee had come to
pretty much to
towards the thinking of of approving
this but the concern then was about the
dimensions of the property
in the plot and we were a little bit
unclear about that and to my mind that
has really been um clarified
and and i feel uh quite a lot happier
about it now now that that has been
sorted out
um
turning to the the solar hot water water
panel i've actually got one of these on
my house and it's very effective but it
is facing
due south on my property
but i know that you do get some effect
from them
facing almost east round to almost west
which
obviously this one is
so it could be better orientated but i
think you'll still get some benefit from
that
and obviously that's within the
constraints of the site
um to my mind this is a relatively
modest dwelling
um
i'm afraid i don't agree with counseling
muller in terms of the design i think
the design actually does fit in quite
well with the conservation area if you
look to the the wider scale of
properties along that and the sort of
various bits of development along that
area
um it's obviously a sustainable home and
i think the parking and turning um could
be overcome
um you know by by the the occupants
using small cars which i'm sure they
probably do
um so i'm i would be happy to um
to to uh to approve this but i'll hear
what others have to say first thank you
chair
um
yeah i i wanted to take advantage of of
um mr pinner being being here the
heritage officer um the the last but one
paragraph of of his piece i was page 16
of the papers
um
the um
really
criticizing the the the
the balance of harms and benefits and so
on so the the and i was just trying to
check to see what the
the harm was
and i see that's
you you're seeing that as as the lesson
substantial harm to the
conservation area
uh not the
the non-designated um asset which i
think the the
next door um
which the neighborhood plan actually
talks about um but particularly to
explain um
you know what you're saying
about the balance but what balance we
should be striking
um
between the the harm and the um
very modest is i think um public
benefit if we could just kind of
understand that a little bit and i think
the other point i can't remember whether
whether i did see that in the report or
not is this business of the view the
view through from the street
um that there are a number of such views
um along the street or am i remembering
back to when i saw this years ago but
that was an issue plea please don't do
that counselor um if you look on page 35
before um mr pinner
advises us on the bottom there um it
says in my view further erosion would
represent undue cumulatively impact
maybe that's what you're thinking of but
if you'd like uh thomas to to give us a
little bit more amplification thank you
uh yes thanks
um yes so i would just say um
these weren't comments by a fellow
colleague but i have talked with a
colleague about um them and i'm aware of
the case can you speak up a bit sorry
i'm just saying um so these aren't um
my words but they are a colleague who uh
did the the latest comments um but i
have spoken to the colleague about uh we
have discussed the case um so possibly
possibly that the um section council
you're referring to is the
uh the section about um
the the diagram of avoiding harm and the
the um
the the the consideration that needs to
be given to the
benefits versus the harm
and i believe this is a
um
question on
considering whether the
public benefits can be achieved in a in
a way that is less or not harmful
i believe it's a reference to the
scheme approved in 2003
and that possibly that was
also provided dwelling but in a way that
didn't it wouldn't have caused as much
harm um so it's about considering
whether the harm
is justified to achieve those public
benefits
yes so this is this kind of point about
about what you compare with
um
in terms of
of benefit and harm
that that you could build
in principle you could build a 2003
permission which would be
less harmful is that that what you're
saying really yes yes correct counselor
thank you for that
um councillor gold
thank you um
i'm sure
of course we're looking at the the
application that's uh that's before us
uh now
and i'm
for me uh and actually i i absolutely
take um i can understand councillor
muller's a concern about that fit
however i think
probably the the contrast between the
proposed building and
the existing the surrounding buildings
is made more stark by having a
um
a grey
line drawing as as opposed to
uh something with colored because i as i
understand it the applicant's proposal
is to
um
that this would have the appearance of a
traditional suffolk
suffolk bar
so and and we all know many examples of
such barns in infield kinds of settings
uh with within our communities so whilst
i understand cancer you're you're
concerned i'm i'm actually a lot more uh
comfortable
with that uh on the on the issue of the
uh the
the solar panels and and so on i i i
go along with uh
with uh cancer melons comments about
uh they may not be perfect but they will
provide some benefit
uh and that is a matter for the upcoming
i don't think
we're saying that this application turns
on
uh the thermal efficiency of the boom
it's something we like very much to see
is a planning committee
but the fact you have the applicant has
made those provisions i think is a is a
positive thing uh and and hopefully they
would um
prove
very beneficial
um
i'm i'm
i'm always
very much guided by
the view of
the parish council as as well um
particularly in terms of a kind of
guardians of the
of the appearance and and character
are of of the of the settlement of the
community uh so for me the support given
uh
by the paris council is is quite
persuasive
and
then to the to the
uh applicant
uh the applicant's family being part of
the community and and all that we know
how important
these they don't always sit directly
within
um within the planning concerns
but um they are um
they are
you know highly relevant here uh
parking and is a concern and access from
the
egress from the property to the street
is is of concern i do feel concerned
about that but with small vehicles and
and and perhaps reversing in and all
these practices that that
harm could be mitigated in and there's
no objection from highways so to cut um
i'm conscious a long story story short
here
i would be
proposing approval of this
application thank you very much
thank you very much to have a seconder
to that please before we move on
counselor melon
yes i'm happy to second that chair
thank you very much yeah i think um me
put my hand up to second this was a bit
of a spoiler for my imposition on it
um
i you'd you'd have to have a very strong
argument to convince me that this
driveway and the heritage
issues are enough to stop this from
happening i think
this is
as in keeping as modern buildings could
be with the area
the um
there's a lot of provision for putting
cars um more so than many of the
existing um
vehicles um the houses there have got um
a parking um
the um
the visual splays i don't think are an
issue you got a pavement and you've got
um
a wide road going through there where
cars actually park on the side
um there's there's a lot right with this
um for me especially as the fact that it
is the definition of local house in need
a um
a young couple want to live in the
village where one of them's um grown up
and they want to um
suggest that they want to raise a family
there
yeah for me yes this is um acceptable
i don't think it does
uh
very much harm i've seen i've seen worse
harm on heritage assets and um yeah i
would i was happy to second it and
at the moment i feel like i'd be happy
to approve it
my point of view i've listened to
everybody's debate and comments and
fully concur with much of it
my main problem here is that
nobody has the right to park on the
highways
and there is a yellow line going down
the street to near to where that parking
is
and we have in our papers a picture of a
car park right across the site so i do
have concerns about that
i also listen um to
our heritage people and we always
complain when they don't come along when
we want them to put up a fight
um for um heritage things and and
heritage is one of those things that
they train and are specialists in and
and we are not um
and i i waver between one and the other
because of the the passion given to us
um i'm not sure that the applicant will
have a small vehicle for his building
work but um i'm sure you can get
something small to suit the the occasion
which is what uh some of our members are
suggesting
um but i do
also look at the work that the planning
officers and the heritage officers have
done
and
as i say
we normally complain when they don't
come along so i do thank you for coming
along albeit not your report um but
supporting it
um so i am between the rock and a hard
place as they say and so i think with
with that
um i think we've said everything that we
need to say and so um if we'd like to go
to the vote at the moment
sorry councillor madison
i haven't actually expressed an opinion
yet
when you don't have to you can press
button b as you can i i well if if yeah
if i might i think my
when
um
with with heritage as exactly as the
chair has said um over over the years
i've always been
quite reluctant to to to disagree with
heritage views
um and i
i think i'd be uncomfortable to do that
on this occasion actually um i i
you know i think particularly you know
paul harrison is a very experienced
officer and i've read his full report
and um
he's um
he's not happy with it and i think the
the
the public benefits
to balance
um and taking account what's been said
um are
are a bit small um
really though it's difficult
thank you for those comments councillor
councillor norris yes please yeah thank
you uh yes as you mentioned a rock and a
half place where i thought it was quite
appropriate in this case i'm in much the
same position actually
i could see there are some
issues regarding the site
um
the access obviously the parking as
we've said
but on the other side there is a public
benefit involved
there are no objections from the parish
council is supported
um so overall i am intending actually to
go along with the recommendation for a
program
thank you
if you could
adam share just quickly um i'm looking
at gemma do you want to go first
thank you thank you chair uh yeah i just
wanted to pick up a couple of things
before we move on to that as a vote in
that we do need to
have a reason for members as to
specifically those public benefits that
we're saying outweigh that harm
and in terms of the parking so if we can
address the two reasons for refusal uh
why did you're taking that alternative
decision i think that's what it was
after plus conditions that you would be
minded to add and just briefly before we
move on to that i would caution
uh the weight that you give to public
benefits um you know appreciate that the
applicant has mentioned for his family
and personal and that kind of thing
unfortunately the weight that we can
give to that
doesn't is not really there so i just
just add caution on that one
as to the weight we get to but if
members want to start with that and then
we can perhaps work through any issues
with the weight but if we could do that
first chair that would be
doesn't mind may i just add some gem as
comments that to get to go back to first
principles
there's there is as you as members are
aware there is a leak when you're
refusing there's a duty to give reasons
which which are suggested here when
you're approving there is no duty to
give reasons however
well if if you if you are approving in
accordance with an officer's
recommendation which you're not here
if there was a legal challenge a court
would assume that you were following the
reasoning set out in the officers report
unless you've indicated otherwise but
obviously where you are disagreeing as
you're perfectly as you i don't know
what the results of the vote will be now
but if you if the vote was positive for
this resolution you would be
disagreeing with an officer's report and
the courts have said that not in every
case but sometimes
they would look looked to see at least a
clear indication of the precise
as it were route to a decision of the um
committee and where where it comes from
and if it disagrees with its officers
where and how so with that in mind i
would invite the proposer and secondary
to reflect on
as as gemma says look at the reasons of
refusal that
they're disagreeing with and say
do they disagree with as they're
entitled to do they disagree with the
officers assessment of a low level of
less than substantial harm
they're perfectly entitled to that
should be made clear but or if they if
they accept it they might think it's a
bit less but it's still a low level of
substantial harm
what how is that outweighed and
do they disagree with reason two which i
assume they do that's about it being um
cramped and having an effect on amenity
so
that's i think general and i have one
mind on all that
goodness
uh
right the
i mean
as i see it it is a legitimate role of
of this committee indeed if this isn't
is not its role then what is its role uh
and it would be uh to to make judgments
about balance uh and and impact and
benefit
uh and in
uh proposing support for this that's
what i feel i i am doing um
the uh
in a sense i am
cognizant taking account of the
heritage officer's advice but as i said
in my reasons for
for proposing this
i think um there's there is another
source of expertise here as well which
is the parish uh council
uh at paris council as we pro our
collective experience is probably that
parish councils
uh do uh
rail against disapprove of uh
applications which
change uh worsen
the character of of the settlement and
here there is a clearly a strong feeling
and support also echoed by the uh by the
ward counsellor uh that says actually
this is uh fitting um
and appropriate uh to to to the setting
there is i think a highly subjective
view
um
and professional views are professional
assessments but
like everything else they have an
element of judgment and subjectivity
to them
and i think
here there is
what is being proposed
is in contrast
but not out of keeping with the setting
of the village and my goodness
it is much more in keeping
than the derelict plot that we've seen
there and is likely to remain and i have
have the degree of relevance that one
would give to that is probably probably
small but in terms my mind and my role
and my analysis of it
makes that uh puts that as a factor
um the um
you know the
the spaces is uh is restricted
um
and
that can present a challenge certainly
uh i don't see i've seen more
more uh restricted
proposals and more restricted
settings than this uh albeit i can't
remember one that was approved but be
that as it may this this is a
constrained site but it doesn't seem to
me to be
such that it would make for an
impractical or unattractive uh
development
and then you get to the um the social uh
benefits which are about as as
councillor custom put it so well
actually this is the best definition of
a local housing need that you can get in
a sense
and
and for all of those reasons i hope
they're sufficiently clear and cogent uh
to meet uh the uh the the formal need
that the officers may have
to support the recommendation
gemma do you have enough from that to
make something that robert can put in a
a recommendation i think i'm nearly
there i might just need to clarify
perhaps some of the public benefit
aspects but if i um mention where i've
got to so the
proposal is to grant planning commission
the parish council and ward
councillor consideration considerations
are that
are that the proposal is appropriate in
the conservation area setting the
proposal is in contrast but not out of
keeping
the plot is constrained but would not
make for an
impractical or unpleasant environment i
hope that was correct with what you said
yep super and the low level of less than
substantial harm are we content that
we're accepting there is that level of
harm
or are you are you feeling that there
isn't any harm and that's where we
should be going i suppose that's
critical for me
opinion on that
it seems i i absolutely understand the
question but it's a kind of
bizarre it's asking for a technical
professional judgment
uh when clearly that is not our our
wrong to do that
um but uh
the only way i can answer your question
is with the word yes
if i think i've got that right way
around so that the the low level of harm
etc
is uh
uh acceptable or is outweighed by uh the
the the clear public benefit
you accept there's a low level of
substantial harm you probably think it's
lower than thomas's colleagues think it
is and you you accept that it's in law
we have to still have
pay attention significant attention to
avoiding that but you you consider that
there is a public benefit that outweighs
it
yeah yeah yeah yes i think i'm saying
that and i
i'll be more confident when i know the
way my colleagues vote on it
if i come back on that last paragraph
then so i would suggest we add in the
word very in that case so the very low
level of lesson substantial harm is
outweighed by the public benefits
including development of the empty plot
local housing need but i haven't added
any more and i'm conscious there were
various other issues so i just wanted to
check was there anything else you wanted
to add in on the public benefits that
might outweigh the harm
i'm really happy to
so so remind me what we've got at the
moment i've got the development of the
empty plot and local housing need
i mean there were ones that
officers would include in their reports
very often about the economic benefits
so
i'm sure you wouldn't wish to not make
those
point your benefits clear in this case
as well why wouldn't you
no that's absolutely fine so i would
then add in so um the very low level of
lesson substantial harmonics outweighed
by the public benefits including
development of the empathy plot local
housing need and economic benefits of
developing in the village location
so that just leaves us then with
conditions
which i would suggest we usually go with
time limit approved plans i assume that
you would be happy for us to continue
with that the conditions as recommended
by our highways colleagues
and
the
conditions from heritage probably
materials thomas perhaps if you could
advise us that
uh yes i
think
paul may have um
suggested some
i think i've got details of the
materials
particular cladding and roof tiles
particularly yeah yeah
and then i suppose my last two queries
are any concerns on permitted
development rights that you would or
wouldn't want to remove it's entirely
within your gift to do so
and perhaps given the parking reason for
refusal perhaps a condition to
give that back to officers to
clarify exactly how the turning works
but obviously on your thoughts on those
now that
that's points it seems very very very
sensible and i i think i heard
councilman matthewson's
say has agreed
to be agreed with officers and
uh again and another convention that um
i think could apply in this case
i i believe we weren't hoping for a
notwithstanding condition on the
cladding materials because it was a
proposed um
kind of
timber of effect we weren't sure if that
would be something that would be in
keeping with the conservation area so we
would want to reserve judgment on
that
until we'd seen
the details but i think it is
mentioned in the submitted documents
yeah
so i mean sometimes we will simply say
um
that the details of the cladding are
essentially acceptable we'd like to know
the color or the maker of it i think
thomas is suggesting in this case that
we would have a notwithstanding
condition so not withstanding the
details submitted we would ask the
applicant to
provide those further details and
perhaps it might be a slightly different
material but that would allow us to go
away and work on that together rather
than simply we're happy just a slight
detail this is a sort of a review of
that generally i suppose
yeah that seemed again seems sensible
and then after that can you run through
what it is and i'll ask the secondary if
he's happy with what you're proposing
thank you sean it's just to clarify the
condition in terms of parking and
maneuvering because highways have said
that it should be as on the submitted
drawing but i think it ought to be that
details that are submitted so we can be
sure that it works
yeah yeah what what i wanted to add
really was just to remind people that
and this is where mr pin is coming from
this is the full application with with
all the details already in it and i
think we're being asked to to actually
pull out some of those
details about parking and about the
materials um in in in what we what we
did voting on right
so
yep that's it so the parking would allow
us to confirm that you can definitely
drive in park and turn appreciate
members points about small cars and
various things unfortunately we need to
stick with highways things so we would
just want that absolute clarity you can
drive in and park looking at the plan i
believe there is room otherwise i
wouldn't recommend the condition i would
say there is no room to park we
shouldn't be doing this there is some
flexibility we would just like a plan so
we've really got that confirmed and
similarly with the materials we think
there is probably something that would
work but we just need to
bottom that out and get that finally
agreed so they would be the two things
that although we've got
more or less the details for we feel
we'd like to take that away and come
back does that make sense
i i i am uh madame chair
happy with that as well um yes i'm sure
oh yes you're the second i beg your
pardon why did i look for councillor
custom i do beg your pardon i'm so sorry
not at all no i'm sure counselor cast
them equally well uh second this um
i was just looking through the mppf and
because i thought there was some support
in there for self-building but i can
only find a little footnote to paragraph
61. i don't know if general if there's
there's something in there that
gives some sort of policy support to it
um i
can't think of anything off hand that
the
issue with self-build normally comes
about with sill in that you get an
exemption if you're a self-builder um
and we sort of support it that way and
there has been some push towards that
that we are expected to achieve a
certain amount of self-builds but the
policy hasn't essentially followed that
up in quite the same way
sorry yes gemma raised the point about
whether members wanted to withdraw pd
rights i don't think we had a an answer
to that and whether it be for extensions
or garages walls
means of enclosure etc extensions
i had added it on but perhaps i was
preemptive um up to cancer gold if
that's can can you tell me what you've
added uh so i'd just gone with remove
posted development rights and i was
probably going to leave that up to sean
but i mean in general we talk about
removing a to e so that's your
extensions
porches roof alterations putting on an
extra story these days that's class a a
class e is your sheds so possibly want
to remove that or not and
then pop
part two class
a is a for um
hard standings
gates rules that's it that's the one we
also normally do so it's a to e
and
the the following bit for gates and
fences
so they couldn't play gate up on that
access
near the highway
it's actually very difficult to answer
uh
that um
so
uh clearly
you know some some of those um more
significant
rights than
extra stories and and and
uh extensions um
uh probably not but um
sheds and
a shed on things you know
that that seems an
unnecessary restriction
to me so
uh i think if you if
you want to um make a proposal
in terms of
the significant
rights that
would would um
as it were offend our agreement of this
uh this proposal i would understand that
but
a blanket removal of
permitted rights seems inappropriate
unnecessary
yeah absolutely so um so class a would
allow you to do extensions around the
house so off the back essentially single
story two story so i would probably
suggest
that's time that would be one we'd want
to take off as you say it's about the
room on the site
um
similarly um we have to
bear with me two seconds while i just
get them up so i've got the detailed
wording for members and there we are
then i can just clarify we're absolutely
clear on which ones we're doing there we
go
so yep a we've just discussed
sorry the text is very long bear within
a second so a a is the additional story
which i'd assume we definitely want to
avoid so we're taking off a and a a if i
make those notes as we go along hey
then b would be uh enlargement of
dwelling house of an additional
alteration to a roof so something like
your um dormer window
i'd probably say that would be out of
keeping with the sort of style and
design in this case and therefore
perhaps that's something we would want
to retain control over and particularly
we've got the void scenario how that
might work so we're looking at b as well
then
c is other alterations which essentially
would be um
the roof lights so you could put in more
roof lights or adjust your roof lights
so perhaps we're happy to retain that in
this case so won't take c off
d would be for a porch
difficult that one whether it's in
keeping on or not already happy to leave
that flexibility
absolutely
i'm
saying this uh without without advice uh
i mean
so many different styles of portion and
and so on i i find that's a difficult
question to answer fine i think in that
case i would say that there doesn't seem
to be good reason for doing so and
that's always the critical thing for a
condition is there a good reason for
putting on i don't think that would seem
to me there is so we'll leave that one
we're suggesting we leave it class e as
well and
that would allow them to sheds or out
buildings and that the albeit there is
not the largest amount of garden space
class e does restrict that in terms of
height in terms of the amount of floor
space based on your garden area so that
there is some control on that one um
and then
if we don't normally propose removing
hard surfaces to actually build a patio
and more driveway
that's not normally something we would
want planning applications for
similarly chimneys and flues they're
already proposing a flu that would
probably be fair enough microwave
antennas and various things we wouldn't
normally just go through those and then
the other one is the part two minor
operations class a
the erection construction maintenance
improvement or alteration of a gate
defense wall or other means of enclosure
now essentially that would prevent them
putting a gate up at that access onto
the road and might be something we wish
to control
i want to be clear why we why we would
withdraw that right you know it might be
uh growing
the family
um you know the ability to ensure that
particularly young children aren't
running out onto the road and so on and
so forth so
i don't see why we would withdraw that
that right
and i just have sean just make a comment
please there is actually a gate proposed
on the driveway but it's so bad but
there is
so we wouldn't then want to change that
in that case absolutely thanks sean
right so i think i'm there so we were
looking at removing a which is your
extensions a a for an extra floory
extra story
b which is possibly door my windows
and that's it
brilliant thank you
with what we're listening to and what
we'll be voting on
uh proposal and second are you happy
with that
in that case then i hope robert's been
typing furiously
thank you chair just for everyone's
benefit and everyone watch i think we
should ask for it to be read out again
by gemma okay
just said that we're all clear yeah go
for it jenna thank you so we're looking
at granting planning permission uh the
parish award council of considerations
are the proposal is appropriate in the
conservation area setting the proposal
is in contrast but not out of keeping
the plot is constrained but would not
make for an impractical or unpleasant
environment the very low level of
lessened substantial harm is outweighed
by the public benefits including
development of the empty plot local
housing need economic development of
economic benefits of developing in the
village location and subject to
conditions
for time limit
approved plans
highways conditions noting that the
we're amending that to not withstanding
the submitted parking layout details of
parking and turning to be submitted and
approved
notwithstanding the details submitted
details of materials cladding and roof
tiles are to be agreed
and remove permitted development rights
specifically class a a a b and d
thank you chair
thank you chair
vote is now open chair if members could
go to the modern.gov app and go to the
plus sign in the top right hand corner
the vote will show in progress under the
subsection of attendance voting and will
show in the light blue color
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is four votes four and
three again so the motion is carried
thank you very much indeed for that um
and good debate and so if we can now
have a very very short
break
thank you councillor matheson i know
your
your your desires on that thank you just
a very short break if you would please
thank you
welcome back everybody
and
so we move on to dc20581
the crofttostop
berries and edmonds
and and now invite the case officer
master to introduce the application to
the committee thank you very much
good morning everyone
the application is for change of use of
common room for use as sheltered housing
flat including alterations to provide
parking
the application site is situated in
defined settlement boundary and
conservation area of tostock and is a
modest plot
consisting of its single-story meters
buildings
the terrace compromises of six
residential units formerly used as
sheltered housing accommodation
the residential units are now used as
general needs housing
the application building is the central
unit which you can see
which was formerly used as a shared
common room
you can see the wider context of the
site
the application site as noted before
is situated in in conservation area and
settlement boundary you can see the
location of the public footpath and also
a number of great two-listed buildings
this is the scale and bulk of the
building there are no external changes
proposed
all the changes are internal
i should also add that this is
retrospective because the work has
already been carried out
under permitted development rights
in 2020 the government released updated
permitted development rights to allow
for emergency developments by local
authority and
a health service body for example
the town and country planning order 2020
allowed for certain types of
developments by local authorities on
land within their ownership or leased or
occupied or maintained by them as and
when a need was identified
so the common rules was was converted
as a need
was identified
and the work has already been carried
out but as i mentioned no external
changes have been proposed
so this is the current layout so it is
provide a provided a one one-bedroom
accommodation and also
additional parking as part of the
proposal
as you can see there's a disabled
parking and also an additional parking
that has been part of part of the works
the emergency power has now expired and
hence the need for the current planning
application before you
and as noted before there are no
external alterations no design changes
with the exception of additional parking
and these are some photos of the site as
you can see
cars park along that road so additional
parking is really a welcome
resolution to this problem your offices
have not found any significant impact on
residential amenity highway safety or
character of the conservation area and
would respectfully ask the members to
agree with officer's recommendation
which is approval of the application
thank you
thank you very much for that um do we
have any questions at all
no
um
in which case um we don't have
a representative from the parish
objective supporter or agent
um
we have have we got anything from the
ward members at all on this one robert
could you read out the we do cheer from
councillor richardson if you could read
out his statement thank you
bear with me one moment sharp i just
have lost it
thank you chair
so
the comments from council harry
richardson ward member uh unfortunately
i will be unable to attend this meeting
i'll be only as a ward member for one of
the items being considered and point
number two i have no objection to
application
dc200581 best wishes councillor
richardson
thank you very much to that
um we move
i think yes into debate because we have
no one else counsellor mueller
thank you chair um i have no objectives
i agree with the ward member
we have come across several similar
applications recently on planning a
therefore i move approval and agree with
the officer's recommendation thank you
oh that's very helpful having had
experience with them do i have a
secondary counselor mathison
secondary yes yes yes yeah thank you for
that
does anybody wish to speak to
motion no
then i think if we may robert if your
fingers are quick to get the
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress thank you very much
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is a unanimous vote
for the proposal
thank you very much indeed um
right site inspections uh do we have any
site requests that need to be reported
to this committee none to report just an
update with regards to the invitation
that went out to members for the site
visit to felsium which will be taking
place on the 20th of october
so if members can be mindful of the 20th
of october please
and that's at 10 30. that's at 10 30 and
the full details will be sent out in due
course to all part all relevant parties
thank you very much indeed and now i
formally closed the meeting thank you
very much for your attendance everyone
thank you
you